can you describe how this model got
created because it feels spot on as a
practitioner yeah thanks well we had the
great good fortune to be invited by the
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation to
work on this model for them you know
they do tremendous investments around
the globe this particular area was their
family health innovation portfolio and
they were concerned that there they
weren't getting enough bang for their
buck that they just weren't investing in
projects that actually would be
implemented and scale-up to be
successful and so they asked us to look
at the literature find out what others
had been doing you know recognize what
models had been developed so far but
then build on them to make it a
practical sort of a model that
practitioners in the field could take up
and so we again built this great team
and then set about understanding broadly
as a foundation theoretical literature
from a whole bunch of disciplines so we
were reading literature from economics
and organizational theory in sociology
and business to get a broad sense of how
innovations new ideas flow that was sort
of a grounding for us we identified a
gap in the literature was that which was
that these models were very theoretical
she couldn't really grab on to pieces of
them in a concrete way so we then as
Christina mentioned earlier I think one
of the strengths of our approach was
that we drew from both empirical
literature and from the field experience
from the field so the first step was to
do interviews with experts from around
the world so we talked to for example a
family doctor in Uganda who works on
neonatal health we talked to a
government official from Brazil who
really led the field there in spreading
exclusive breastfeeding as a behavior in
that environment we talked with a
researcher in Pakistan who'd been
studying community health workers there
for decades so people with very rich
experience that was the first step then
we turn to the empirical literature
these two million are nervous
you know to see what had been studied
and what we could learn in four in types
of family health innovations and so that
was a systematic literature review and
then we turned back out to the field
this last step was i we call it pressure
testing but it really just means
inviting critical feedback from experts
and so we heard from hundred experts
from around the world kind of an
intimidating process but so valuable
because they really helped us refine
ideas concepts of a model that needed
clarifying just a couple of examples
this idea of user group that christina
has mentioned we ought to be very
precise what we meant by that this
notion of receptivity we haven't really
talked about that yet here but what does
it mean for a community or a user group
to be receptive to something not need or
demand but openness to innovation so
that last step of pressure testing was
really critical to refining the model
really getting the wisdom from people
from around the world so that was the
process fantastic thank you so much so
maybe we should dive deeper into this
model aided tell us more about each
component so we we start with assess and
again emphasize the non-linearity you do
always want to do an assessment and
people do that but this is a process can
often be ongoing as you introduce the
innovation but actually first let me
take a step back because we also want to
be clear that we are thinking about two
discrete entities thinking about the
user group as Lesley mentioned and also
thinking about the innovation itself and
paying attention to both of those things
the environment around the user group
and then thinking very carefully about
how they would come together so in the
assess step we would understand really
the user group and the environment
around it so let me come back to the
door to balloon example that I mentioned
earlier which again was an effort to
reduce the time when a patient with a
certain kind of heart attack from the
time that person get to the door of the
hospital until they get a treatment that
puts a balloon in the artery to less
than 90 minutes so door-to-balloon time
less than 90 minutes to understand how
to implement some evidence-based
practices to do that the groups that
were involved in
door to balloon time really assess the
hospitals how were people already
dealing with those patients how were
they brought to the hospital how was
communication happening and what was a
regulatory environment around us
hospitals that was influencing the way
that people were conducting the patient
care and then also thinking about the
practices themselves so it's the steps
of dealing with that patient from the
time they realized that patient has a
certain kind of heart attack until the
time that patient gets the treatment how
do we look at that step be a series of
steps and get it to less than 90 minutes
so that segues into that's all assess
that's the a and that segues into I
which is innovate so that's the next
step I'm just go on and that as I
mentioned before is really focusing on
the innovation itself so there were
there was a set of steps that needed to
happen for the patient to get balloon
within 90 minutes and how can that be
tailored to the user group so people
really thought carefully about can we
have any wiggle room and add
adaptability in these steps how do we
have the nurses speak to the doctors how
do we have the emergency response
personnel speak to the people in the
hospital and there were some areas in
those steps where there could be
adaptability to make it fit to the
hospital where it was being implemented
so those a couple of examples of a and
the eye of a did great Leslie so I go to
d I guess develop develop is I think you
know an interesting step in both
examples will go to the community health
workers to sort of illustrate this idea
but as Christina described as briefly
the developed component of aided
requires us to really think very
carefully about the context context
matters the political environment the
economic environment the organizational
structural environment and so paying
attention in this stage to these
environments can help us cultivate and
in a space in which an innovation can
take root we need to be thinking about
you know who stands to lose what are the
turf battles what are the various kinds
of incentives or mow
vations in this particular environment
how do we use data not just scientific
evidence but all kinds of data to help
create a space in which an innovation
can can grab so in this community health
example there was a group of Nepal who
were interested in having the community
health workers expand the role of
practice I mentioned some of the kinds
of things community health workers do
typically and in Nepal they had been
doing distribution of vitamin A very
successfully for some period of time and
this multidisciplinary group wanted to
have the community health workers do
more in particular do case detection and
treatment of pneumonia and government
officials didn't really have faith that
these lay health workers would be able
to do case detection and treatment very
successfully a health workers typically
low literacy living in very rural areas
off and unpaid and so the the group that
was advocating for this kind of growth
and scope did a pilot study in a couple
of districts and showed that in fact
these community health workers were
perfectly capable having been trained to
do case detection and treatment of
pneumonia and so that the pilot program
really gained the credibility of the
government officials and so they made a
government decision to spread that
program to 42 districts across the
country so it's an example of sort of
taking the environment and seeing what
needed to be done and and kind of
changing it in a way to be more
welcoming of the innovation so then I'll
pick up the e the engage step and this
is really as I mentioned before really
the kind of when the rubber hits the
road I guess you say where the
innovation comes together with the user
group and so as I mentioned before this
is thinking about boundaries thinking
about how things come in thinking about
making the innovation accessible to
people who will be using it and then
ultimately getting to a place where it's
integrated into the norms and practices
of the user group so the door to balloon
example it started the innovation was
actually again evidence-based there had
been
studies of how to reduce door-to-balloon
time and then that was developed into a
set of practices and a toolkit which was
adapted to fit the hospitals but how was
it brought in and so we think about this
idea of a boundary spanner an individual
who can bring something into an
organization is welcome there somebody
already brings something in and that
could have been a quality improvement
officer sometimes it was a cardiologist
sometimes it was a person who had
familiarity with the literature but
someone who already brought something
new in so that's fit and then
introducing the innovation to the user
group across the boundary and then the
next component of engage is to translate
the material or the messaging of the
language of the innovation so that it is
accessible to the people who actually be
using it so again with door-to-balloon
it was taking that academic language and
making it something that the people who
are actually going to be implementing
those steps and really counting the
minutes found accessible and felt that
they could do and this is also a
component of engagement writ large is to
make sure that the innovation is
understandable and usable to the people
who are actually going to be using it
and then the final component of the
engaged step is to integrate so that's
actually when the innovation is not
really new anymore this is sort of
becomes part of what we do around here
that's when you transition from
door-to-balloon time of 120 minutes to
90 or less and that's the last piece of
engaged when you see that happen the
innovation has fully engaged with the
user group it has now become part of the
DNA of the organization it's a normal
part of the way that people do things
excellent thank you so much in the final
d okay and for the final d and evolve
innovations if we've done AI de well
innovations may spread across all kinds
of networks personal professional peer
networks relationships and the
devolution happens organically so maybe
if we come back to our community health
worker example one more time
in Thailand we have a good example where
the community health worker model has
been in place since 1978 and there in
that particular cultural environment the
role of community health worker is
highly prestigious and highly valued and
so for an individual to assume a role as
a community health worker they often
stay in that role for their lifetime and
when they want to retire or leave that
role often it is handed to a child or to
a family member and so we can see the
devolving of that role across
generations in that environment and that
particular cultural value and norm has
been seen as a really you know critical
facilitator to sustainability of that
model over time excellent thank you so
much well we've explored some of the
difficulties of implementation and
scale-up then we've listened to some of
your examples from around the globe and
introduce this new model and I guess I
only have one final question for you and
that is how does this model help someone
who is a practitioner or professional
charged with making change introducing
new ways of working well one of the
things that I really like about the
model is that it has these five steps
and it's we hope it's very
straightforward so it's informed by
extensive literature and talked with
practitioners and pressure testing with
scholars in the area but at the end of
the day it's five steps that we've we're
hopeful will resonate with people who
are in the field we're really saying i
have this innovation here's my user
group how can i bring these two things
together and implement this change such
that it's it's sustainable and also
scalable thank you so much yeah I might
just add that you know the request from
the Gates Foundation really was that we
create a practical model not another
sort of theoretical conceptual piece of
work that would sit out in one of those
two million articles a year that we keep
talking about but rather could be used
in the field and so that was our charge
we were very intentional and being
thoughtful about how these components
actually might be done in the field
and so in addition to the report that we
prepared for the foundation and the
peer-reviewed articles that we published
we've created a practitioners guide that
we've really worked with practitioners
in the field to develop and so that's a
resource available to people who want to
understand what does this really mean
assessment what does that look like how
might I go about doing that and so we've
got that we maybe could make available
to viewers if they're interested
fantastic Leslie Christina thank you so
much for your time and expertise today
and thank you for joining us for what we
hope is the first of many conversations
on implementing and scaling up best
practices in healthcare I'm say Hiram
mcnatt until next time